did you ever wonder what would happen if
Aaron won against the alliance and
destroyed the entire world what would
happen to the Paradise Island and his
friends would Aaron manage to finally
bring true peace to his people or would
it all be in vain well before we talk
about what exactly would happen let's
first quickly cover three ways Aaron
could have easily won in the final
battle for example the very first and
obvious thing Aaron could have done is
not allow his friends to use their
abilities the only ones who had a real
chance to take him down were the other
Titan ship and depriving them of their
power would have been an easy win for
Aaron but how would he even do this well
back in the paths when Aaron convinced
air to lend him her strength he unlocked
all the abilities of a founding Titan
using those Aon could have easily
modified all the eldians as he pleased
and stopped other Titan Shifters from
using their powers after this no one in
the world would be able to stop him as
the regular weapons do pretty much no
damage to Aaron and his army in this
scenario it's most like likely that the
alliance would still try to pursue Aaron
and make him change his mind but without
their Titan Powers they wouldn't get
very far and would most likely die at
paradise's Harbor way before they ever
had a chance to talk to Aaron although
the decision to steal his friends Titan
Powers would allow him to easily destroy
the entire world you have to agree that
it doesn't really seem like something
Aaron would actually do as he always
wanted to give his friends the freedom
to fight back however there are still
two more ways Aaron could have easily
won in the final battle and this next
one is even simpler than the previous
one back when Aaron started the rumbling
flock immediately knew that his friends
would try and stop him so he captured
kiomi and the engineers in order to
prevent the alliance from using the ship
although flock was well prepared for
this battle there wasn't much he and his
soldiers could do against two
experienced Titan Shifters like Annie
and Riner so in the end flock could only
buy Aaron some time but what if I tell
you that Aaron could have done one
really simple thing that would pretty
much ensure his and flocks Victory Aaron
could have easily left a few colossal
Titans to help flock guard the harbor
and stop the alliance from pursuing him
with the presence of the Colossal Titans
it'd be pretty much impossible for the
alliance to win this battle even if they
find a way to somehow defeat the
Colossal Titans it still wouldn't matter
as flock would have more than enough
time to sink the ship before anyone gets
on board just like he wanted to do in
the original story but was stopped by
Gabby this would make it impossible for
the alliance to follow Aaron and would
lead to him destroying the entire world
with no one standing in his way but I
guess Aaron didn't really think of that
and chose not to help his biggest
supporter which ultimately resulted in
flock dying poor guy all he ever wanted
was to help Aaron hit the Subscribe
button to make him feel better anyway
even though Aaron didn't take his
friends powers and even though he didn't
help flock in the harbor he still should
have easily won against the alliance in
the final battle by doing basically
nothing let me explain one of the
biggest reasons Aaron lost in the end
was because Zeke died and the rumbling
stopped this meant that the alliance
didn't have to worry about marching
colossal Titans anymore and could focus
all their strength on taking Aaron down
now at first it may seem that there's
nothing wrong with this but if you think
about it for a moment there's actually
no reason for the rumbling to stop after
Zeke's death let's go back and take a
look at a few moments from the anime so
you can understand exactly what I mean
firstly when Zeke and Aaron came into
contact both of them were transported to
paths where Zeke was able to negate King
Fritz's vow to renounce war after that
Zeke gained full control of the
Founder's abilities which he was going
to use to euthanize eldians however Aran
managed to convince Amir to give him the
powers in exchange for giving her the
freedom that she deserved considering
the fact that Amir herself decided to
support Aaron Zeke's importance here no
longer matters and his death shouldn't
have caused the rumbling to stop Amir is
the one who gives the powers to Titan
Shifters and she should have been able
to easily continue the rumbling if she
wanted to now some fans believe that
despite amir's wishes Aaron still needs
to be in contact with someone with royal
blood in order to keep using the
founders Powers but that's not really
true you see back when Aaron touched
Dina Fritz and used the coordinate for
the first time he commanded nearby
Titans to devour her after a few moments
Dena was dead meaning that the
connection he had with Royal Blood also
ended and he shouldn't be able to
control the Titans any longer right well
not really because even after the
physical contact the Titans still
pursued beral and Riner instead of the
soldiers unlike the situation in the
final battle where killing Zeke
immediately stopped the Colossal Titans
dena's death didn't yield immediate
results and Aaron was still able to
command the Titans for a much longer
time if we consider this and the fact
that Aaron had Air's full support in
continuing the rumbling it really
doesn't make sense for it to stop so
suddenly due to the complexity of the
attack on Titan story there's probably
some way you could try to explain this
but the fact is that if this weird thing
didn't happen the alliance would have no
chance of winning and Aaron would
continue the rumbling until the whole
world is destroyed with with that we
covered three things Aaron could have
done to win in the original story but
now comes the interesting part what
would happen after that well after
researching the attack on Titan story
for a long time I found two possible
ways the story could go from here and
the second one will completely blow your
mind after the Colossal Titans finish
their March all the alliance members
would be dead from fighting the Titan
Shifters Aaron created initially Aaron's
main goal was to be free and Grant that
same freedom to his family and friends
now however having lost everyone he ever
cared about Aon would fall into
depression and start questioning himself
and his actions still having a strong
sense of Duty Aaron wouldn't just give
up now and would decide to modify the
remaining eldians to completely
eradicate the curse of air and prevent
any more casualties caused by the power
of titans this was always Aaron's
intention and now that there is nobody
in the world capable of hurting eldians
it's finally the right time to do it
after that Aaron would convince Historia
to rule the people of Paradis as their
one and only Queen while he goes into
hiding this would work well with Aaron's
character as he never had intentions of
ruling or being worshiped he just wanted
to do what was best for his people and
now that his plan has exceeded there's
no reason for him to show himself
anymore the remaining survivors on the
island would probably work towards
building a modern civilization similar
to Marley and the rest of the world
although this kind of seems like a happy
ending for the eldian people it won't
stay like this forever you see although
there are some people who supported
Aaron's decision there were many others
who were against it even though there
isn't an outside threat anymore with
time it's inevitable that new conflicts
will eventually arise and peace will be
broken once again there's a quote from
the anime that perfectly summarizes this
when Titans were the greatest threat
Titans were the enemy when countries
were the greatest threat countries were
the enemy for as long as people hold
firm to different beliefs there will
always be an enemy in the end achieving
Eternal peace was never a real
possibility and finally let's cover the
most interesting scenario yet here Aaron
will embody his true character of a
villain the one we see throughout the
final season of Attack on Titan during
this season Aaron seemed like someone
who was fully engrossed in his own
Ambitions to the point that he became a
completely different person however in
the end during his conversation with
Armen we learned that Aaron did this
because he wanted to carry all the
burden by himself so his friends could
be free in this scenario he'll stay true
to his villain character and will take
the whole burden of destroying the world
on his shoulders we can all that aon's
actions near the end of the show were
questionable but his main goal was
always to Grant his people something he
himself could never achieve Freedom with
no guilt after destroying the entire
world Aaron would use his powers to make
one final decision completely wipe away
memories of all subjects of air he would
make sure that no one remembers the
rumbling in the outside world completely
freeing them from all terrible things
such as war and conflicts this will
allow eldians to freely explore the
world like Aaron always wanted to do
with Armen and masasa granting them true
Freedom King Fritz has tried to do
something similar in the past when he
created the walls and brought his people
to Paradise isent however in this case
there were still a bunch of threats
outside the walls like Titans Marley and
pretty much the whole world Aaron's
decision although similar has a much
better chance of succeeding and bringing
peace to his people ultimately Aaron
would also free everyone from the curse
of Amir and the power of Titans ensuring
that history never repeats itself again
wiping the memories will help Aaron
blend in with everyone and try to live a
normal life however as the sole bearer
of his terrible actions and memories of
freny lost it's unlikely that he'll ever
be truly
[Music]
happy